Welcome back everyone this is good to be my
new marvel daredevil video there was some
great news recently.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs and a big plan
for the daredevil characters in the MCU going forward
So if you're new to the channel, be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'll be doing
videos for the Hawkeye series after marvel
what if finale which is happening this Wednesdays
were gonna be getting a whole bunch of stuff
really soon, but you may have seen the news
this past week making the rounds that Marvel
is planning a new daredevil series that will
take place after the current group of series
that they're working on right now bringing
back most of the main cast of the daredevil
Netflix there's without completely changing
their characters are recasting a bunch, which
I think is what most people were asking for.
It's not exactly daredevil season four.
But all explained what it seems that the plan
is just based on the next couple of series
and all the other marvel Disney plus series
and marvel movies that we know the characters
going to cameo in but the ideas that leading
up to this daredevil revival series daredevil
and kingpin at least will appear in a couple
other marvel Disney plus series and possibly
marvel movies you may remember last year when
it was reported that they were planning on
bringing daredevil and kingpin back in the
marvel Disney plus series.
The marvel movies.
We known about that for a while, so that the
Hawkeye episodes coming up in November.
I will be doing full episode videos for that.
Just like I do for the other marvel Disney
plus series like what is like the Loki series
like Wandavision during that they're going
to be introducing the Maia Lopez echo character.
This is what she looks like she's going to
be one of the antagonist.
You could say one of the subtitles for the
series should be.
Let's kill Hawkeye.
Because it seems like pretty much everybody
except for Kate Bishop wants to kill Hawkeye
on that series, least of all Val and yelena
belova from the black widow post credit scene
Loki like a Shar are responsible for your
sister's so during that Maia Lopez's echo
will be one of the antagonist.
But she is it core daredevil character in
the comics, whose father was killed by kingpin
who they're also supposedly bringing back
the kingpin takes her as a child and pulls
a thanos like thanos destroyed or balanced
Gamora's homeworld.
Depending on how you look at it perfectly
balance is all things should be raised her
as his own child to become this hardcore assassin
she is canonically death and they cast the
deaf actors to play her character.
Like I said this is who she is she standing
next the Hawkeye and you notice he's wearing
a version of his comic book accurate purple
costume from the Matt fraction Hawkeye run
that they're adapting for the Hawkeye episodes.
She winds up developing a very taskmaster
likability to copy people's moves on the fly
echo people's moves.
Thus the name echo also kind of radar to like
daredevil has his special site ability.
Like you can't see but he can kind of see
is the same thing with echo in her hearing
before she learns daredevil secret identity.
She winds up falling in love with Matt Murdock
separately.
But kingpin sense echo to kill daredevil trying
to get rid of him lying to her telling her
that daredevil was responsible for the death
of her father she's powerful enough to defeat
him in combat.
But while she's about to kill him.
She learns his secret identity the daredevil
is Matt Murdock the do that she had recently
fallen in love with she spares him in eventually
learns the truth about kingpin lying to her,
so she is a very electrolyte character in
that respect.
Like another antihero in the MCU who has a
relationship with daredevil and as I've said
in my Hawkeye trailer video vincent d'onofrio's
kingpin is supposed to have some kind of cameo
scene towards the end of the Hawkeye episodes.
But he's not a really big character during
that series.
The idea being that somebody hires Maia Lopez's
echo character to kill Hawkeye.
During the events of the Hawkeye series because
of her connection to kingpin the whole idea
being that Kate Bishop Hawkeye's origin story
and her family are heavily connected to the
mob in the New York City area.
It just based on all the Hawkeye trailer footage.
If you haven't lived in New York City, or
not familiar with the New York City landscape
based on the footage it seems like most of
the series takes place between hell's kitchen
on the west side in Midtown East so make sense.
It will be some Hawkeye crossover with the
characters from the daredevil Netflix series,
because so much of the series takes place
close to hell's kitchen but supposedly the
ideas that they introduce Maia Lopez's echo
character during this reintroduce kingpin
is a proper part of the MCU vincent d'onofrio's
kingpin.
Just to be clear and then you probably heard
the news about them doing a full blown echo
spinoff series on Disney plus during that
series.
The ideas the kingpin would be a much bigger
character in the echo series is overall would
feel kind of like a daredevil season four
with more the characters coming back without
actually being a full-blown daredevil season
four.
Like the timeline of the characters would
be such that the series picks up after the
events of daredevil season 3T most of their
origins in continuity with what's happened
in the MCU recently.
Like the events of Spider-Man no way home
in the Loki series and during that supposedly
that's when Charlie Cox is daredevil comes
back legit for some of those episodes.
There was also report early last year the
Charlie Cox was supposed to come back in the
she hulk episodes as a version of Matt Murdock
because she's a lawyer for superheroes who
works in the New York City area will be nine
episodes and the be using the series for a
bunch of different cameos.
Not just abomination and Bruce Banner hulk.
So makes a lot more sense that Matt Murdock
was chauffeur cameo scene on something like that
But though she hulk episodes won't be released
till early next year the echo episodes were
where the be way more these daredevil characters
coming back wouldn't be released till like
really late in 2022 or 2023, but is after
those after the echo episodes are released
per this new report that Marvel would do the
daredevil Netflix revival series.
But as a soft reboot inside the MCU proper.
So the timeline makes sense.
Like according to the report marvel just to
change a few minor aspects about the characters
back story so that it makes sense within the
existing marvel movies and Disney plus series
that have happened up to the point daredevil
Netflix and the other marvel Netflix series
were already connected to the marvel movies,
but a lot of the references that they made
were kind of vague or they would come up with
other names are big MCU events like they had
another name for the avengers movie in the
battle of New York you never heard them referencing
the avengers by name a whole lot they would
always have funny ways of mentioning them
like they refer to Capt. America is the flag
where instead of just calling him Capt. America.
So they the ideas the by the time they're
actually ready for release these new suppose
a legit daredevil episodes still have cameo
and a lot of these characters in other series
have a pretty solid idea for what's going
on in their lives in present day MCU.
When those episodes eventually pick up all
right going so that she a rider that snaps
mass mindset one with a wide right right right
right right though there were any kind of
reports about with the story of this new daredevil
series would be or who the new main villain would be
We know kingpin would show up beyond that
we don't know which other brand-new comic book characters
they would pull for it.
Bullseye is still out there.
But the last we saw him at the end of daredevil
season three.
He completely gone off the rails and Eve been
masquerading as an evil daredevil wearing
the costume to make people think that daredevil
was evil then he turned on kingpin who broke
his back, so it's not like they're gonna be
working together anytime soon, leading up
to him though getting his proper origin story
moment with the adamantium spine.
There were so many theories about than doing
the adamantium spine that being sort of a
gateway or a teaser for what was happening
with mutants during marvel phase 4 marvel
phase 5 bull's-eye has his trademark sharpshooter
abilities, but also his adamantium spine makes
an extra damage resistant and it destroyed
his pain receptors.
So he doesn't feel pain during fights, leading
to push himself beyond normal limits.
Like plus ultra yes, there are all the Spider-Man
no way home daredevil Matt Murdock rumors
I haven't actually seen any footage of him
from the recent trailers that show him there
was a brand-new IMAX version of the trailer
the provide some extra context though this
or of debug some of the rumors, there a lot
of people that thought that Matt Murdock might
show during this interrogation seen what is
being grilled by the police about Mysterio's
video in the drones character slams his forearms
down the table and allow Cooper.
Like maybe that's Matt Murdock.
I did not kill Mysterio the drones day the
drones that are yours.
But what happened was they release this IMAX
Spider-Man no way home trailer you can actually
see the actors phase in his this actor here.
So very clearly he is not Matt Murdock.
So he does show up during the movie is going
to be during some other part most people are
just focused on trying to spot Tobey Maguire
in Andrew Garfield Spider-Man like there the
top of everyone's Detective list if daredevil
winds up appearing in a new cameo scene, they'll
just be icing on the cake another lot of questions
about what's going on with Val and the Hawkeye
episodes of the echo episodes is she going
to be recruiting more people more antiheroes.
My assumption right now just based on what
was seen so far in all the teasers in the
post credit scenes is that she will probably
have a cameo scene during Hawkeye because
of the yelena belova black widow post credit
scene.
Just to provide some connection back to that
in her mission to kill Hawkeye for whoever
it is that they really work for another lot
theories about that based on all the reports
from the marvel movies that they're currently
filming right now like Black Panther to it
sounds like Val is going to be showing up
in a bunch of future projects.
So it might be a while before they completely
pay that off my expectation right now is that
that thunderbolts team that it seems like
she's putting together one as she fully be
paid off until we get to something like Capt.
America for will be couple years before we
see that movie.
It will be really cool, they turn Capt. America
for into like a dark avengers movie like we've
all been expecting thunderbolts.
But what they go full-blown dark avengers.
So Val is going to recruit someone from the
Hawkeye series, it would probably wind up
being echo what will happen is my marvel what
if episode nine finale video will post on
Wednesday, then the Hawkeye episodes will
start after that will get a new Hawkeye trailer
really soon and new Spider-Man no way home
trailer, so of course will do Easter egg videos
for all that stuff.
If you have any big questions about what's
going on in any of the series, or any the other trailers
just let me know in the comments below what
you wait for everything.
Click here for my full venom let there be
carnage post credit scene video, and Spider-Man
Easter eggs and click here for my brand-new
marvel Eternals Trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!